uh travis threw me a few times
a lot of times when he was visiting in
austin and i just remembered uh so
there's two things i
fortunately or unfortunately in my life
haven't gotten a chance to train it with
folks of that level
without just cleanness of throw and the
power and it was very nice i ca i
immediately actually enjoyed being
thrown like that
to throw a little [ __ ] at craig jones
with his current matte situation
um
is they're very they were quite thin
uh and as travis commented on not just
the thinness of the mats but they were
laid on like concrete right so i felt i
felt it it's like soft until it's not
um
but uh
being thrown very cleanly i just felt
like there's this is not gonna lead to
injury it was great it wasn't injury
prone but then as i mentioned to you
when i a day or two after my entire leg
one of them i guess it's the left leg
um
was just
just black bruised
it didn't it didn't hurt too bad but it
was just the body's gotten soft so i
guess the question is um
does the body get used to
just that number of throws just over
time being thrown thousands of times a
month
unquestionably your body gets used to it
so it hardens it gets really hard which
is why judo is is hard to come back to
after you've taken a long period of time
off because your body is not used to
that impact anymore
um i always found out that you know when
i was training judo a lot it's hard to
it's hard to uh shed weight and keep
weight off because your body like you
know it
it develops like this layer of
protection on itself that it doesn't
want to give up yeah you know when
you're sucking a lot of weight that
means you're frail and you know so i
always seem to retain weight more you
know when you're doing hard judo
training as opposed to
you know losing weight it's easy when
you go for runs and things like that to
to shed the water weight but to actually
keep the pounds off was yeah pretty hard
yeah the body kind of develops like you
said a level of protection
you